hi everybody my name is Sal frangie I'm
a spark expert an instructor and I have
a confession I'm not the data scientist
he's supposed to say we love you pal
okay so even though I'm not that a
scientist I'm going to talk about
tensorflow and not not necessarily the
date the data science aspects of it I
have to get used to this okay so the
question I get a lot I got into
tensorflow
six months ago and I started working
working with it and the question I get a
lot from even from that assignment is
does tensorflow replace spark or big
data so actually there's there's no real
direct relation the both handled
data at scale but they are more complete
complementary technologies so big data
is about handling a lot of data which is
either structures or semi-structured in
discrete and sparse deep learning is
about handling analog and structured
data and which is dense either in terms
of space or time but it's more dense so
in many cases they are totally used for
different applications
now deep learning is it seems like big
data was is the after the hype term like
everybody are already in big data all
the banks all the insurance company
everybody is in big data and that's how
I get hired to do spar consulting and
deep learning is just beginning and
everybody's starting to push deep deep
they're learning to everywhere but
actually it doesn't suit every
application ok so that's that's the
question so if that's that's the case
why why can why if waiking with it why
can we take things from spark to tend to
flow so I'll show what the the seams
that are
similar so in terms of operation
normally you don't start your own cloud
when you work with spark you've got some
kind of provider like data bricks or
Amazon EMR you don't start your own
cluster the same is true for for getting
into tensorflow deep learning if you
need a GPU machine you normally need to
either buy it or in most cases get it
from a cloud provider you need
monitoring in spark I've seen at least
half of your computer expert in spark
you have the spark UI and accumulators
to help you monitor and see what's going
on in data flow we have tensor below in
terms of verdun in the summaries and
compared to also and in terms of
programming the paradigm is not revealed
so getting into spark is not the same
programming in spark is not the same as
programming a simple program you have to
understand the functional model that's
behind it you're building a crew station
or graph in that respect
getting into tensorflow and learning to
program 10 server is similar you need to
understand the construct that you're
building using your programming language
and it's not revealed for most for most
programmers the use of of notebook
they're playing in the case of over
spark and tensorflow does not have you
as a good support for for notebook I'll
show some support I wrote for Jupiter
but it's not as nice as the the notebook
support for spark the cost is also a
factor in getting it to in to both of
them in spark you have when you're
running when you're running a lot of a
lot of executors if you pay by the hour
to the cloud provider and here you have
expensive GPU and a cost and in terms of
languages Sparky's Scala or Java
back-end and you couldn't program it
using Python tends to float back in with
C++ and the front
language is is a title okay so when you
start learning tensorflow the first
thing you see in the tutorials is d is
the handwriting amidst data set so it's
a great tutorial and it's if you wanted
to start with tensorflow go ahead and do
it but for my taste it it's too great
it's it's too clean it was engineered to
work through all the steps and just work
out of the when you download it and you
go to the steps and it work when I when
I get to learn a new language or a new
platform I try to invent my own problems
to see where the dirty where the dirty
sides are what they don't show you in
the tutorial so I wanted to find problem
which is quite similar to this but my
own so I took her I invented myself for
an exercise myself it's an emerging
exercise I took 16 by 16 icon same as
the enemy and I have the small dataset
and what I wanted to do is a simple
classification problem is it is the icon
I see that are emoji smiley and a sad
face a smiling face or if it's a
different icon so we have a simple
classification problem just to learn in
tensorflow
the the problem is is quite sparse we
had 68 emojis out of all these data set
so it's not a perfect data set to learn
that I learned a lot going through it so
it my first tip or advice is when you
learn something besides the tutorials
try to get your own invent your own
problem so here's the data set or part
of it and here is what we want to
classify to find the emojis so I started
out I'll not go to through the code but
I started with a simple regression like
model actually didn't give any good
results
because it just said okay everything
isn't the best bet would be everything
is not emoji because it's very sparse
but I learned by ramming it I still
learn something so running this on my
laptop just took forever it's running 10
server it just never finished took a lot
of time so I said okay here's the
problem I probably need the GPU ok so I
wrote myself a script you can find it on
github that allows me to do what I do
with spark many times every company I
come from a guy come come to and start
consulting i buildin the infrastructure
for the engineers and the data turn it
is to be able to start a cluster fast
and turn it shut it down fast what why
is that important because the because
the cost of starting in a cluster or
summary of GPU machine is the barrier
for you to to try things
if you lower that barrier people try
more and it will cost you less because
if the Varia is high people start a GPU
machine and then they go home and they
say well tomorrow it would take me half
an hour just to define a new machine I
won't shut it down and suddenly the the
cost for the companies for GPU machine
being up all night starts to rise so
being here items on DevOps sometimes
it's hard but you can do it in Python
beyond DevOps they manage your resources
manage your GPU machines or cluster it's
very helpful so you can find a small
utility of github to start in a deep
learning machine so what I did I ran it
on a GP machine what I got is that the
GPU is in zero percent utilization
there's a tool from Nvidia which you can
run on the GPU machine it can do
anything with the GPU so my problem was
not that my laptop was too slow so I
moved my my codes to using batch batches
of code so this is this did
thing well it started to work the the
last function and it started to converge
and this is also ran faster on my laptop
apparently I did not need the GPU right
if I was utilizing it for three percent
on the GPU machine probably I'd probably
don't need the GPU what I mean it was to
move to working batches so that's a
lesson learned so my my regression model
did not identify the emojis yet but what
we learned is that the the GP is not
necessarily the problem it's more how
you build the system okay so the what is
happening and what tensorflow does is
take the the calculation the noontide
model everybody's familiar with what
Moonpie does it does most of the
calculation in C it maintains the data
structure in C and Python is just a
wrapper when you multiply two matrices
it does it under the hood in in C++ so
10 suppor took it another level what you
do in Python is define a full
computational graph and actually the
full computational graph runs in with
C++ in the background right so the less
you do with Python and the more you move
to be working with siccola plus the more
you gain in terms of performance so this
is also something you need to learn when
I told you about the program project
you'll need to understand how to make
the code work more in C++ and less at
doing the stuff in in a Python when I
move the reading the examples themselves
the the data from being read by Python
and fed into them into tensorflow to
using tensorflow inputs you can convert
the data to ten suppose a propriety and
format which is DF record you get the
C++ code to read
data process it and give you the result
and pison is not even involved in all
that okay in one project I work later on
we use spark to take the data and
convert it to a to a format that can
also focus in read natively which makes
the learning later faster so you need to
understand how the platform works be
more than just understand your your
modules or network you need to
understand what's working under the hood
so the next thing that helps you learn
most most the data sense live in Jupiter
right how many of you live inside
Jupiter okay so that some some program
is living in Eclipse
you know so actually so sensible does
not lend itself that easily to to
working with Jupiter but I did some
wrote some utilities that will help you
wrap the things needed for tensorflow
inside Jupiter one one thing
specifically that your session inside
Jupiter will also start tensile board
which which is the visualization tool
for for tensor flow so again the Spartan
inspire you have already working a
notebook called called Zeppelin and then
working you I called spark UI which are
integrated tensor flow it's still not
there but I try to do something with
these utilities which you can download
so you can play are you can play with
inside Jupiter you can play with the
with the tensor flow you can run several
learning stages and see what happens in
this example and writing running a
hundred steps for the optimizer to run
and I look at the loss and out decreases
and you can also see that the loss going
down in the pencil board UI okay there
it is very important to be able to play
interactively with the operators because
you want to use tensile force operator
that are executed in in C++ you need to
learn them and understand and there's no
better way than interactive interpreter
so playing in Jupiter and trying around
what does concat do is very important
that's why I encourage you to work
inside an interactive environment okay
then so tensorflow has our tester board
has also interim summaries which are
visual for example you can you can
visualize the the images you're
processing you can even visualize the
weight metrics of each layer you can do
that by by sending the images to tensor
world but sometimes you need to write
code in terms of Rho that will convert
your weights into images and you can do
that but you need to master that piece
also okay so in generally use
visualization you can use the
visualization that you can use print
it's powerful
I mean don't hesitate to just print the
loss or print whatever you want that
helps you you can use tensor board and
you can just use Jupiter itself with all
kinds of visualization that help you but
from my experience visualizing how the
mobile acts step by step helps you a lot
in the first stages so it is an example
of tensor board and visualization I've
used it shows you the the the specific
icons it processes and this is their
activation layers the levels of weight
the activation okay so what did I get
from this emoji exercise in terms of
classification so I didn't do a really
good
job because it's a very sparse data so I
got a hundred percent recall and 78
percent accuracy will see that this
accuracy is better actually and why is
that so this is the this is the actual
labeled emoji for my let's call its best
model this is when I uses a single
hidden layer that it was too large I was
overfitting
and this is a good good result so I
didn't get all the images but what is
interesting is that my model find this
one which is it was not labeled but if
you look at it you can see it is anymore
d2 neatly so if your model find things
that were mislabeled if it's generalize
generalized in a good way right so that
for me it was a magical moment to see
that my model generalized and found
something that was unturned so that's
that's my my personal exercise of to
close it up and use scripts to to move
to the cloud and work on a GPU machine
visualize either insensible either
intense aboard or outside play to
understand the construct of the of the
stencil flow and feel free to use my
utilities to work inside inside the
Jupiter that's all I hope I've been
short enough thank you
you